[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour et bienvenue dans le sais tu ce
week-end sur tv 78 de l'actualité des
loisirs pour bien terminer la semaine
dans les yvelines nous sommes le
vendredi et 15 octobre voici le sommaire
c'était il ya un an le 16 octobre 2020
le professeur d'histoire-géographie
samuel pâtit était assassiné par un
terroriste
cette semaine de nombreux hommages lui
sont rendus notamment dans le collège du
bois d'aulne à conflans sainte honorine
là où il enseignait est la commune
organisera également un rassemblement ce
samedi son maire l'eau en gros c'est
notre invité l'image a fait le tour de
l'actualité emmanuel macron crampons aux
pieds vêtu d'un maillot et d'un short le
président de la république était à
poissy jeudi pour les 50 ans du variétés
club de france un match de football
caritatif aux côtés d'anciennes gloires
du ballon rond et puis comme chaque fois
notre sélection des idées de sorties
dans les yvelines rassemblement mustang
à la verrière ce samedi ou encore pour
les amateurs d'art l'exposition l'étoile
dans les yeux à voisins le bretonneux
elle se déclinera en atelier olfactif
dimanche et ce sera bien sûr dans la
deuxième partie de cette émission avec
bixente mairie ressenti steban bonjour
bonjour grégory et justement je parlé d'
ateliers olfactifs tout à l'heure vous
allez mettre nos narines à dure épreuve
exactement cette semaine john lennon
gêner le nom parce que on vous proposera
justement un petit atelier comme ça de
découverte et de parfums mais on
parlerait aussi d'un festival des mots
un qui se tient ce week-end à
rambouillet ce sera tout à l'heure dans
le sais tu ce week-end
mais d'abord l'actualité avec cet
hommage un an après au professeur samuel
pâtit le 16 octobre 2020 l enseignant
d'histoire-géographie a été sauvagement
assassinée visé par un terroriste à
suite à un cours sur la liberté
d'expression où il avait montré est des
caricatures du prophète mahomet ce
vendredi 270 élèves et 300 professeurs
du collège du bois d'aulne à conflans
sainte honorine là où il exerçait se
sont rassemblés pour un moment de
recueillement et demain samedi une
nouvelle cérémonie d'hommage est prévu
dans l'enceinte de l'établissement
cette cérémonie sera réservé à la
communauté éducative et aux élèves le
ministre de l'éducation nationale jean
michel blanquer devrait être également
présent et pour ceux qui le souhaitent
ceux qui souhaitent se rassembler
également il est possible de se
rassembler devant le collège du bois
d'aulne sur le parvis du collège à une
retransmission audio sera assurée de
cette cérémonie pour y déposer des
fleurs et aussi signé un livre d'or et
c'est également dans toutes les écoles
de france aujourd'hui qu'il ya eu des
commémorations en la mémoire de samuel
paty et demain samedi un an jour pour
jour après cet attentat terroriste la
ville de conflans sainte honorine se
mobilisera pour honorer la mémoire de
samuel patine cérémonie est prévue sur
la place de la liberté où un livre géant
sur le thème de la liberté d'expression
sera inauguré pour en parler lors en
brosse est avec nous par visioconférence
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes le maire de
conflans-sainte-honorine on imagine mal
sept plaies se cicatrisent est
totalement un jour le drame restent
encore aujourd'hui très présent dans
l'esprit des conflanais il a marqué à
jamais la ville de conflans de conflans
sainte honorine
c'est également un drame qui restera
dans l'histoire de la ville de conflans
sainte honorine il y aura quoi qu'il
arrive dans l'histoire de la ville un
avant et un après 16 octobre 2000 et je
le disais il ya des donc des cérémonies
de recueillement qui sont prévues au
collège du bois d'aulne y en a eu
aujourd'hui on aurait une également
demain samedi à 14 heures 30 elle sera
privée mais je le disais tout à l'heure
pour ceux qui le souhaitent ils pourront
se rassembler sur le parvis du collège
où une retransmission audio de la
cérémonie sera assurée pour y déposer
aussi des fleurs signe un livre d'or et
à 15h30 toujours samedi l'hommage de la
commune sera rendu sur la place de la
liberté à moins d'un kilomètre du
collège du bois d'aulne c'est important
pour vous de pouvoir proposer ce temps
de recueillement pour les habitants qui
puisse se souvenir justement de la
mémoire de samuel pâtit
oui c'est un temps important bien sûr
pour l'ensemble des habitants de la
ville de conflans sainte honorine
chacun a été marqué durablement marqué
par par cet attentat
et je pense qu'un en un an après chacun
a besoin de se rassembler pour pour ne
pas oublier
investi pour discuter je pense que ces
rassemblements ces hommages c'est aussi
une forme de thérapie collective
un an après l'attentât en lors de la
cérémonie un livre géant sur le thème de
la liberté d'expression sera inauguré
comment est née cette idée de ce livre
géant comment s'est-elle concrétiser
le souhait que nous avions entendu
l'hymne de confiance et un tony c'était
à la fois de rendre hommage à samuel
pâti en tant qu'homme mais aussi
de rendre hommage à ses mails pâtir tant
que professeur et nous savions que il
avait beaucoup de valeur et nous
souhaitions rendre hommage aux valeurs
qu'ils incarnaient on va alors qu'il
représentait aux valeurs qu'il avait
fait sienne et en particulier à la
liberté d'expression
et donc les l'idée c'est que vraiment ce
livre qui sera installé place de la
liberté soit un symbole un symbole qui
soit un hommage fort à samuel pâtit
l'idée vraiment c'est de rendre à la
fois encore une fois ma chasse à l'homme
mais aussi à ses idées et on sait que
liberté d'expression était un sujet
fondamental pour lier est encore une
valeur que nous devons défendre jeanne
la société française donc il sera
dévoilé ce livre leur bassin lémanique
vous le dites demain 15h30 sur cette
place de la liberté à conflans sainte
honorine une dernière question il ya un
an le président du conseil départemental
pierre bédier s'était dit favorable à la
question ou non de rebaptiser du nom de
samuel pâtit le collège du bois dole
c'est trop tôt encore pour l'envisager
il faudra envisager peut-être dans
quelques mois
j'ai d'irak à l'année est vite passé et
pour reprendre l'expression consacrée il
faut laisser du temps au temps
il ya encore des collègues de samuel
pâte y ait encore des élèves qui ont eu
comme enseignant qui restent traumatisés
par ce qui s'est passé
demain ce sera sans doute une première
étape faire faire le deuil et en même
temps on sent que sur place l'ambiance
est encore est encore présente c'est
bien bâti est encore dans les esprits
ssrt est une lourde charge pour les
élèves comme pour les professeurs que de
voir renommée des parents le collège de
bois donne celle pâtit donc je je peux
comprendre bien sûr utiliser encore
besoin de prendre du recul et d'avoir
d'abord encore un peu de un peu de temps
à titre personnel je suis bien sûr
favorable mais encore une fois je
comprends chacun a sa sensibilité et le
drame est encore sans doute trop présent
dans les esprits au sein du collège pour
renommer dès aujourd'hui dès demain le
collège cm elle pâtit attendons le temps
qu'il faudra mais mais attendons et on
revoyait un les images aussi de cette
marche blanche qui s'étaient tenus
quelques jours après le drame elle avait
rassemblé des milliers de personnes
autour de vous à conflans sainte
honorine et effectivement sur place nos
journalistes avaient sondé cette forte
émotion qui régnait lors de cette marche
blanche merci laurent bros d'avoir été
avec no merci à vous je rappelle que
vous êtes le maire de
conflans-sainte-honorine ce 16 octobre
un an jour pour jour après l'assassinât
du professeur d'histoire-géographie une
cérémonie se tiendra donc place de la
liberté à conflans sainte honorine elle
débutera à 15h30 et à parmi les autres
hommages rendus on peut aussi citer
celui est de la ville de paris 1 qui
inaugurera ce samedi un square samuel
paty et se fasse à la sorbonne à
versailles les rencontres france
parkinson se déroule ce dimanche on
compte environ 200 mille malades en
france 25 mille nouveaux cas sont
décelés chaque année et parmi les
nombreuses idées reçues parkinson ne
touche pas uniquement les personnes
âgées une élingue courtoise a accepté de
nous parler de sa maladie nadège s'est
vu diagnostiquer cette maladie à l'âge
de 48 ans une rencontre signée mélanie
poquet
les mains 30 à peine il y a quinze mois
nadège lascols a subi une opération pour
être électro stimuler mais il y a dix
sept ans elle se rend compte que quelque
chose ne va pas elle a 48 ans j'avais
dans l'avant bras droit
comment des reins
une vibration permanente je veux pas
parler tremblements mais c'était tout de
même dérangeant
j'ai mis ça sur le dos de la fatigue
c'est une amie et collègue marié un
médecin qui lui prend rendez vous avec
un neurologue qui diagnostique la
maladie après l'annonce des moments
difficiles puis l'acceptation avec son
époux on a régné les quatre enfants leur
a dit bon
on va on va foot est au courant on va se
battre tous ensemble
contre ça c'est une horreur c'est vrai
mais bon on n'y peut rien on va être
unie et on va y arriver en fait sans
doute un peu plus aujourd'hui qu'avant
sur dans la maison d'un parce que bon
allez fatigué donc je prends un peu plus
mais pour l'instant je nettoie mais je
connais bien des cas où les ce qu'on
appelle les dents jusqu'au mon épouse
aime pas beaucoup ce terme là elle parle
plutôt long terme et manquent aidant au
début c'est pas c'est pas énorme on
arrive j'ai pu vivre quelques temps
presque normalement
c'était que je travaillais à plein temps
et au début mes collègues ont vu que je
fatigue et un petit peu donc ils m'ont
pris mes services de récréation c'est
tout mais ça suffisait largement
et puis après
ça va plus bien
on se prend un mi-temps et et après la
mi temps ne suffit même plus
là il faut bien bien songé à s'arrêter
quoi l'ennemi juré du parkinsoniens doit
être le fauteuil voilà il faut le fuir
il faut bouger il faut vraiment vraiment
être loin nadège et son mari se bat
contre cette maladie au sein
d'associations philippe et délégué
départemental de france parkinson
et pour les rencontres france parkinson
l'association organise un ciné débat ce
sera ce dimanche à 19 heures à l'ugc
roxane de versailles le documentaire de
nathalie joyeux et parkinson mélodies
sera retransmis il raconte l'histoire de
chantal jupe est une professeure de
musique touchées par la maladie de
parkinson ce jeudi les légendes du
variétés club de france se sont
retrouvés à poissy au stade léo lagrange
une rencontre de gala pour les 50 ans du
variétés face aux soignants du chu de
poissy-saint-germain-en-laye et parmi
les joueurs présents sur le terrain le
président de la république en personne
nickel et demi d'euros et justine
brasier était sur place le président de
la république a chaussé ses crampons le
temps d'une rencontre sportive ce jeudi
14 octobre emmanuel macron s'est déplacé
à poissy pour jouer un match du variétés
club de france au stade léo lagrange
le numéro 3 a joué milieu de terrain
défensif aux côtés de rudi garcia vous
rappelle qu'en 2017 président macro est
venu avec son équipe de sécurité
faire un match contre le mans en équipe
de l'om et ça s'était bien passé le
président est quelqu'un qui lâche pas la
faire sur le terrain comme on dit c'est
la bel air est très content de jouer
avec nous donc quand tout le monde
trouve son plaisir dans un match ça fait
une bonne équipe c'est une porte de
sortie par rapport à son métier entre
guillemets de président de la république
c'est la première fois bien sûr qu'un
président de la république en activité
et faire match de football sa part
d'ailleurs de mettre le maillot c'est
pas commun et c'est curieux de le voir
là ça reste le président de la
république il ya du respect quand même
pour la fonction est pour nous et je
pense que c'est une belle fête ya les
grands noms et l'important c'est de les
avoir je pense que c'est formidable quoi
et parmi les grands noms participants à
la rencontre sonny anderson leur boulot
christian karembeu ou encore alain
giresse
un match deux équipes les joueurs du
variétés club de france ont fait face
aux soignants du centre hospitalier
intercommunal de poissy saint germain en
laye qui était heureux de jouer de faire
ce match et puis c'est une façon de le
récompenser de tout le travail qu'ils
ont pu accomplir pendant sept durant
cette épidémie je pense ça continue
aussi également oui voilà donc c'est une
nouvelle belle après midi près de 1500
spectateurs étaient présents pour
encourager les deux équipes se
respectent et ça joue bien en plus c'est
dans une bonne ambiance avec des petits
retraités
qu'ils ont des banques qui reste comme
il dit une bonne ambiance et franchement
ça continue comme ça il se débrouille se
débrouillent tous après bon le président
sa première fois que le bois joue aussi
j'étais mort c'est plutôt morale voire
et puis bon ça va ça se débrouille sont
plutôt ils ont boudé de brest victoire 6
1 pour le variétés club de france un
match caritatif jouets au profit de la
fondation des hôpitaux présidée par
brigitte macron présente lors de
l'événement un chèque de 50000 euros
sera remis à l'hôpital de la mère et
l'enfant de kaboul
et il est de retour en plateau bixente
mejia sortie steban pour ses idées de
sorties loisirs qui est toujours en
place en plateau mais vous n'étiez pas
sur le terrain aux côtés du variétés
club de france n'ont malheureusement je
n'ai pas pu faire détecter par arsène
wenger ou autres où il y avait un beau
plateau notamment avec arsène wenger
alors pour votre sélection des idées de
sorties bixente la direction rambouillet
à présent avec le festival des mots qui
se tient durant tout le week-end à la
bergerie nationale oui et cette semaine
d'ailleurs nous recevons aura berger
député des yvelines en tant que
présidente d'honneur de l'association
les amis du sud yvelines vous êtes en
direct de la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet bonjour
madame berger après un premier événement
du festival des mots à montfort l'amaury
qui avait connu un certain succès en
septembre dernier vous revenez à la
bergerie nationale la bergerie nationale
pendant tout le week-end tout d'abord on
vient prendre un peu la température
puisque vous êtes sur place etc
officiellement le festival commence
demain mais je crois savoir que quelques
ateliers sont prévus aujourd'hui pour
les classes de collèges et lycées
notamment c'est ça exactement m ce beau
soleil de la bergerie on accueille tout
au long de la journée des scolaires avec
évidemment leurs enseignants
documentaliste ont été à la rencontre
d'auteurs d'illustrateurs de plasticiens
d'artistes ils ont fait des jo politique
avec la maison à triolet aragon par
exemple donc commencer dès aujourd'hui
les c'est une journée vraiment dédié à
la jeunesse et donc demain et dimanche
le festival sera ouvert à tous avec la
présence d'auteurs calque tels que le
philosophe raphaël enthoven ou encore
philippe besson quel va être le
programme rapidement
alors le programme c'est sont justement
des rencontres des temps d'échangés de
rencontres avec les auteurs et temps
d'échangés de rencontres avec des
artistes plasticiens une centaine
d'artistes plasticiens joël du pour moi
qui était derrière moi qui expose dans
le pigeonnier de la bergerie nationale
association hélium je vais essayer de
vous montrer d installation poétique à
whisky ont été mises en place par la
maison à triolet aragon des dédicaces et
puis aussi du spectacle vivant puisqu'on
aura des spectacles de marionnettes pour
les plus petits valentine bobby hull
city serait là pour un très beau
spectacle s'appelle l'anguille et des
lectures musicales donc voilà grande
grande variété d'activités et de
découvertes tout le week-end à la
bergerie nationale superbe à écouter
merci beaucoup aux bergers d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je rappelle que
le festival des mots à la bergerie
nationale de rambouillet c2 samedi 16
octobre à dimanche 17 octobre programme
comme vous l'avez dit ateliers tables
rondes expositions encore performance
artistique pendant tout le week-end et
même pour les plus pour les lève tôt à
des petits déjeuners avec les auteurs le
matin exactement et sous le soleil merci
aurore bergé on retrouve bien sûr tout
le programme sur le site internet des
amis du sud yvelines après on va parler
de belles voitures bixente elles seront
de sortie ce week-end à la verrière mais
en effet grégory si vous êtes plus
voiture que lecture je vous conseille
donc de vous rendre à la verrière demain
samedi 16 octobre un rassemblement
spéciale dédiée aux mustangs pendant
toute la journée à 11 heures ça commence
avec une parade dans les rues de la
ville à 14 heures si vous n'êtes jamais
monté à bord d'une de ces belles
cylindrées grégory c'est l'occasion avec
des baptêmes à 3 euros au profit des
restos du coeur à 15 heures une
démonstration de danse country et enfin
16 heures un show de cheerleaders au
total pour l'événement plusieurs
dizaines de mustang de toutes les
générations
joindre l'utile à l'agréable aussi en
faisant une bonne action en arrive au
moment tant attendu on en discutait tout
à l'heure on va tester nos performances
olfactives exactement c'est le moment de
dégainer votre nez à saint germain en
laye l'entreprise le parfum en herbe
propose des ateliers pour confectionner
son propre parfum notre journaliste
c'est la gatte sango a testé pour vous
cette expérience
je me trouve dans la boutique le parfois
en herbe situé à saint germain en laye
ici on peut confectionner son propre
parfum grâce à l'aide et aux conseils de
marie pierre le car la gérante du
magasin allez suivez moi
marie pierre bonjour
alors on a à peu près deux heures pour
confectionner votre propre parfum au
café nous allons faire un petit peu
d'anatomie vous pourrez choisir votre
valorisateur de parfum et après on passe
cours de chimie création du parfum n'est
pas super convives à sion on ne peut
débarquer martin
[Musique]
alors marie-pierre on va débuter cet
atelier olfactif oui voilà avec plaisir
donc on va commencer par un tout petit
peu d'anatomie pour bien comprendre le
système olfactif chaque fois que vous
sentez une odeur et on en sent en
continu toute la journée les odeurs
monte dans le nez se prennent dans ce
petit fils et olfactif et il ya un
message qui partent directement dans le
cerveau après un petit cours d'anatomie
on va maintenant faire des petits jeux
pour découvrir les essences de création
seulement avec l'odorat une expérience
un peu compliqué voilà un premier petit
est d'ailleurs merci donc juste un petit
filet on sent l'odeur qui montent donc
dans des parfums il peut y avoir des
fruits des fleurs des feuilles mais on a
plus de 1200 matière à notre disposition
qui sont naturels donc là c'est une
première catégorie qui est très
importante en parfumerie pour donner de
la fraîcheur au moins la famille des
fruits au moins la famille de fruits
donc c'est pas un frein malheureuse
c'est un agrume à l'aréna fait et
maintenant dans les agrumes
[Musique]
en tout je vais faire pas moins d'une
dizaine 200 heures différentes avec plus
ou moins de mal deuxième étape vous
allez choisir votre vaporisateur de
parfum j'ai choisi un format un peu
carré autre étape décorer son flacon
j'ai fait une ambiance bohème hier
fleurs et papillons troisième étape la
création la composition de votre part
l'étape la plus importante dans un
parfum il ya trois classiquement trois
étapes la note de tête la note de coeur
et la note de fond on a parlé du nombre
de matières qui sont à la disposition
des parfumeurs donc entre mille 3000
matières différentes donc je vous ai
fait des bases de création c'est à dire
qu'il ya déjà des notes qui sont
mélangés et qui s'équilibre comme il
faut il y a donc plus d'une centaine de
senteurs une dizaine par flatte mais
première étape les notes de tête le
choix entre deux accords ensuite la note
de coeur huit choix on doit en retenir 3
donc pendant que je fais cette côté de
préparation oui je me disais finalement
est-ce que le parfum qu'on choisit c'est
le reflet de notre personnalité
forcément c'est le reflet de votre
personnalité et c'est aussi souvent des
référents que vous avez c'est à dire
qu'on revient souvent à des notes qu'on
a aimés sur quelqu'un après c'est aussi
souvent leurs plaies d'une personnalité
vous êtes très exubérant vous avez envie
d'un parfum de cuisson fort pour vous
faire remarquer il peut vous êtes de
nature très calme nous allons peut-être
chercher un parfum vraiment cocooning
pour vous simplement pas simplement un
petit cours de chimie commence dès chère
équipe est en main je dois donc doser en
mettant plus ou moins 200 heures en
fonction des notes de tête des notes de
coeur des nattes deux ans
voilà j'ai fini j'ai mon flacon en main
finalement c'est assez simple il suffit
de choisir les senteurs que vous
préférez maintenant si vous voulez vous
aussi créer votre propre parfum rendez
vous sur le site internet de la boutique
allez moi je m'en mets une petite dose
[Musique]
et pour revenir sur cette expérience
célia vous êtes avec nous sur le plateau
bonjour célia alors je racontais nous un
petit peu ce qui s'est passé vous avez
appris des choses non oui j'ai appris
plein de choses intéressantes comme par
exemple les agrumes qui sont très
importants pour la fraîcheur en
parfumerie alors il faut aussi savoir
maîtriser toutes les notes parce qu en
les mélangeant on obtient en bien sûr
des senteurs différentes par exemple
l'accord cola je sais pas si vous savez
mais en parfumerie ces composés de
vanille de cannelle et de citron vert et
dans cet atelier je préfère le dire
parce que c'était ma crainte en arrivant
toutes les senteurs que propose
marie-pierre s'accordent vous ne pouvez
pas vous retrouver avec un parfum qui y
sent mauvais même si au finalement c'est
tout une question de goût d'accord c'est
un travail en amont en fait que ce sera
exactement c'est ça pour que ça sent bon
quoi qu'il arrive alors j'étais de vous
faire sentir mais parfois je vois du but
à l'image allez hop
gmt
le 8 on va faire exactement le petit jeu
que j'ai fait moi même c'est à dire que
vous allez essayer de reconnaître un peu
les senteurs
moi j'ai un peu de framboise est-ce que
très bien oui il ya un peu de phrases
framboises en effet hockey après
j'arrive pas de celles restant n'ont
cessé fruité ça c'est sûr les frites et
non moi je
aller peut-être je me risque à la poire
peut-être la poire non pas toi il y a en
fait de l' orange du citron et des
feuilles d'orange et en notes de tête
ensuite en notes de coeur on retrouve le
lys le manioc la l'iris la mûre et la
framboise comme vous disiez visualité et
enfin on note de fond la vanille et le
caramel
ok super et chaque parfum non on voit
bien dans les pubs bien petit nom pour
ce parfois justement c'est à dire oui je
les nommer douce folie marie pierre m'a
dit que j'ai des noms assez accrocheur
qu'il fallait donc douce folie parfois
merci beaucoup c'est dire donc bah si
vous voulez faire votre parfum vous
pouvez aller voir seulement le parfum en
herbe et faire vos petits noms à la fin
du coup chacun peut mettre nommer son
propre père se créer son parfum lui
donner un nom personnalisé la bouteille
en tout cas merci c'est là nous avoir
fait découvrir cette activité alors une
exposition d'art bixente à présent et
croyez le ou non il ya un rapport aussi
avec les senteurs et oui dès demain
samedi 16 et jusqu'au 24 octobre une
exposition a lieu à maison de covile de
voisins-le-bretonneux quel rapport avec
les odeurs justement et bien dimanche un
atelier olfactif est proposé avec
certaines oeuvres de l'exposition je
vous laisse découvrir plus largement
l'expo avec ce reportage
l'exposition l'étoile dans les yeux de
la maison de covilha voisins le
bretonneux ses onze artistes pour autant
d'univers c'est vraiment une exposition
très très riche c'est une expérience
très enrichissante des mondes qui se
mélange entre sculpture et peinture avec
par exemple dotées de l'or noir peintre
de bitume j'ai choisi du bitume parce
que le bitume
c'est l'origine du monde en fait c'est
animal et végétal et minéral
cette provenance quasi mystique des ces
trois entités de la nature le lui
confère des qualités aux propriétés
étonnantes et indomptable ou encore du
collège pour christophe rougerie tout ce
qui dysfonctionne au fait dans la
création artistique c'est ce qui
m'intéressait les coulages
les déchirures et puis aussi je fais
tout en extérieur je n'ai pas d'atelier
donc c'est la nature qui prend aussi un
peu le relais lola public levron une
exposition organisée par la société brin
de france et rte 10 nes on est attiré
par des univers artistiques qui sont
voilà un petit peu disparate et ce qui
donne un ensemble
assez large klein qui peuplèrent a
vraiment tout type de public parmi les
temps forts le vernissage d'ouverture le
samedi 16 octobre à 17 heures en
présence des artistes et quelque chose
d'un peu plus insolite le lendemain
dimanche 17 à 16 heures nous avons donc
un atelier un parcours olfactif à
travers quelques oeuvres petit plus de
l'exposition tous les fonds récoltés
seront reversés à l'école aime la vie un
établissement pour enfants en situation
de handicap basée à boisin le bretonneux
objectif leur permettre de s'acheter du
matériel d'art voilà comment mêler tous
les sens pour cette exposition d'art
alors si tu l'habitude aussi bixente on
a vu ce qui se passait ce week-end le
week-end prochain aussi 23 et 24 octobre
un peu de musique de pamiers en effet on
va s'arrêter un tout petit peu avant le
week-end puisque le jeudi l'étoile
montante de la soul française kimber
rose revient après plus de deux ans
d'absence elle sera au concert donc le
21 octobre au prisme d'elancourt pour
son nouvel album out petit extrait de sa
chanson sauveur
ces connards
tout ça
mon sens
à l'être chez les jeunes
non
pour ma part rien
[Musique]
tiens un retour donc pour vous donner de
la bonne humeur rendez-vous 20h30 dans
la grande salle du prisme en réseau et
réserver tout de suite votre place sur
le site du prisme d'elancourt on me
souffle que vous avez un autre coup de
coeur au prisme oui en effet grégory
j'ai coché dans mon agenda la date du 27
octobre le spectacle de marina rollmann
une humoriste suisse que j'apprécie
beaucoup on termine par la nuit des
châteaux ça se déroulera donc sur les
week-end des 23 et 24 octobre avec
notamment deux châteaux yvelinois à
thoiry à dampierre qui se prête au jeu
mais exactement c'est la nuit du coup du
23 octobre une petite sortie nocturne
avant halloween la semaine suivante le
but de cette soirée sensibiliser à la
préservation du patrimoine au château de
dampierre donc la visite se fera pas mal
en extérieur avec l'élimination des
jardins à la bougie une soirée sous le
thème du coût des jardins attribuée à
andré le nôtre at war is est plutôt donc
en intérieur avec l'ouverture du château
nocturne des visites guidées à 18h30 20h
et 21h30 sur réservation uniquement par
téléphone ou par mail et comme pour
dampierre à thouars et l'éclairage se
fera aussi à la bougie donc une bonne
idée de sortie avant halloween est ce
que vous savez déjà votre déguisement
pour le 31/03 il ya une sérénade fixe
qui cartonne en ce moment je vais pas
rester mais peut-être que ça pourrait
être basé là dessus un costume de
couleur rouge peut-être peut-être avec
également au programme merci bixente
pour tous programmés c'est déjà la fin
de cette émission mais on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine comme d'abidjan pour
donc le 7-8 week-end lundi ne manquez
pas le retour du 7-8 journal un pour
avoir toute l'étendue de l'actualité
locale dans les yvelines d'ici là passez
un très bon week-end sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]